salut tout le monde et ben voilà on est
de retour
alors encore une partie phildar mais
comme vous avez dit la dernière fois au
bout d'un moment il n'y avait des
parties handicap et donc c'est le cas
dans cette partie vous allez remarquer
donc il n'a pas de clients bien
incertain on n'a pas de plus rift est
donc évidemment les noirs sont mieux par
contre la partie une pièce de plus mais
le pire reste quand même c'est un pion
pénibles ne pas avoir évidemment
puisqu'il y aura des points sur cette
diagonale à 2,8 et aussi éventuellement
la halle et en science direct pour voir
donc il rejoue contre vannes brûle le
même s'il a battu la dernière fois on a
vu que c'était serré alors peut-être
qu'avec une pièce demain bonne bouille
la séchante 4 ou 6 petites françaises f4
et cavaliers h 6 avril vient se placer
éventuellement pour bloquer ici est ok
admettons qu avec trois des cinq 5 c5
ces trois cas ici sinon le début de
partie est assez logique floue détroit
pour pourquoi pas notamment qu'il
refusera le fouillent quant à elle
semble plus tard mais au moins ça
développe
bon là un coup un peu moyen peut-être ce
qui avait lieu cette c'était sûrement
possible de faire mieux
jean salins par exemple jécistes avec
l'idée de faire bouger cette de roke est
de cacher le roi ça a l'air assez
logique quelque part je trouve que deux
retouches et un cavalier mais admettons
alors petit rock il y avait 5 pouces et
deux faisaient est là
philidor a montré une nouvelle fois une
bonne bonne compréhension enrouée
comprendre ce qu'elle est pénible niveau
le chasser il est moins à faire h3g 4
bon le problème c'est que lyon va faire
j'ai quatre tables on a besoin de faire
trois bien sûr que si on veut des g4
surfer g4 et jusqu'à il prend peur ok
pour commencer si on fait h3 le problème
c'est que s'il ya un trou ici donc
qu'est le cavaly qui va venir l'autre il
ya venir là on retrouve bloqué de
majorité allaient le roi qu'on va le
circuit à grand chose les noirs prennent
position des bonnes qu'avec leurs
cavaliers cpi du coup il va jouer ta
main pour couvrir les cases fou 17 ans
qu'il fait des quatre ans nous mettons à
l'oratoire f8 un peu étrange
je pense qu'il verrait mallard ok on va
dire pourquoi pas et g3 très bien ils
préparent h3g 4 parce que si h3 tout de
suite il y avait foule h 4 si on bouge
la dame
on a vu la manoeuvre des noirs
d'installer deux cavaliers de tout
bloquer c'est pénible et bien sûr on n'a
pas trop envie d'échanger je rappelle
que quand cela parte avec une pièce de
moins et alors à ce moment là
ben j'ai une finale c'est pas trop le
délire ok alors j'ai 3 les noirs ont
fait ces 4 alors là aussi je trouve ça
un peu peu mou en rappel bonne foi de
pièces de plus donc si jamais ils
échangent et qu'il joue pour s'activent
pour ces 8es faire d'un v6 faire du jeu
sur des quatre c'est camille père
logique et bien sûr ils sont très bien
en plus dans toutes les structures de
française normalement faut chercher à
faire du contrôle sur le centre blanc
donc ces quatre ses rares souvenirs
mais bon il reste toujours très bien
mais surtout avec sa pièce 1h 3g 6
ok j'ai quatre également y fait son plan
kg h4 et un coup pas mal up vivian g5
donc il intercepte la défense il attaque
le cavalier et il attaque aussi l'objet
les noirs aprem qui ont faim et
d'évoquer tout va bien je faire kf3 mais
finira bien calculer après tout reprend
tout reprend il saute pas sur le
cavalier les s'enclenche prend l'air ils
firent rage et deux intermédiaires des
champions attaque la tour surtout qui
doit s'en aller et il prend 1,6 hélas
dès maintenant ça va quoi en fait avec
les gens ils à cette compensation
il est arrivé à petit à petit remonté un
peu remonté la pente
le truc c'est qu'on voit que les cases
noires sont assez faibles donc si
toutefois vous là bas ça va pas être
simple et noir et peut-être même venir
bloquer la porte en livres 6 et salah
ben ok la relève noir ont fait 27 et il
joue donc le bon coup h 4 près partout
g5 du coup si on fait grand roque avec
les normes se prend l'enfilade angers
son mari l'a fait d'un les fuites mais
fou g5
du coup le roi est bloqué le fou peut se
prépare à mr bloqué pour l'instant c'est
très bien joué contre plus de
masterpiece par des blancs pouces et 6
mai cette harpie jusqu'à maintenant
manière c'est là ça patine un peu je ne
sais pas trop ce qui se passe pourquoi
il fait pas j'ai pas le truc logique qui
en fait des folies 6 on l'a dit c'est
assez logique quoi pourquoi parce que
soient les noirs nous font rien et on va
fermer et du coup là en otage la qualité
ça pas grand chose parce que la console
comme ouverte va être bloquée 2-2 ce
pion là va pouvoir pousser h5 et avec
l'aide du fou et tapé là bas et
créatures batterie ça va être très
pénible
donc en gros le noir soit ils vont
rendre la qualité comme ça mais c'est
quand même pas simple pour eux parce que
les blancs aux enfers d'un me cinq dames
centraliser la tour va prendre la
colonne et pourquoi pas rentrer là
dedans quand le payons très resserrée
très bon à ce point noir l'autre option
c'était sur fotsis de se dire oui mais
je peux prendre ce pion basse quiévrain
peut prendre ce pion may à jessains la
dame s'en va et h5 du couvent atacado ce
pion en cas de prise la dame arrive on
va prendre ça et pas facile pour les
noirs parce que on va encore continuer
s'il faut
pour attac h7 partout rachat par exemple
disons si noir défendre une fois de plus
et ben ont fait tour à chaque coup
suivant fou prend h7 et la mobylette est
parti donc
[Musique]
donc en fait après faute si je pense que
fils d'ange et était très bien mais il
patine un peu il fait à 3-3 et que ça
pas grand chose bessin dame de sainte
croix g3 séparément des fautes mais on
sent qu'il ya pas eu moins de fil
conducteur que si vos débuts dame e3b 4
et encore une vision un peu étrange
il prend et du coude ou vendre une
colonne ce qui favorise le camp qui a la
qualité prise d'armes cran et du coup
les noirs peuvent consacre au filet et
voilà donc c'est un peu à une mauvaise
mauvais passage henri d'amd de b3 il a
mis le fond d un et dames 1 et là on va
dire les noms ont repris l'aventage
parce que les blancs n'ont pas pu
fructifier ce que je vais faire les lois
et
hé hé ouais il rentre la fage 5 mai
l'a22 brûle
while joue pas très bien parce que il se
met en mode défensif qui vous faire dame
bien je vais défendre
on va voir comment ça continue mais il
était vraiment temps avant de se
refermer la porte d'accès de tous hyper
important tour active est notamment très
fin qui était très fort puisque on
attaque ce fou et sur un groupe comme
fois f3 par un pion prendre et ensuite
on fera danois pour jeunes finale et
nacion qui a été de plus dans le final
c'est bien de deux options b2 on sait
pas trop qui veulent défendre dans la
forme et dans bien le prendre et je
crois que c'était très bien pour les
noirs ça mais ok tu aimes bien été joués
du coup bien joué de la part du leader
qui enferme la toile écrue f6 ont
refoulé certes on sait pas trop pourquoi
mais bon puis on prend et il a pris du
plomb ou encore une mauvaise décision
pourquoi ces positions parce que ça nous
serions passés quand même qui a 2 càs de
dames et en fait c'était quand même
beaucoup plus logique de prendre de la
dame est d'essayer de faire un blocus
d'autant plus que même sûr c'est que la
dame ait pas un bon joker pour l'instant
le foot pas venir cette diagonale il ya
les pions qui défendent toutes les cases
donc on a pas s'en soucier
du coup les bancs devoir contourner fait
un truc comme g53 h 4 h 5 est ok c'est
possible mais ce qui se passe
ok disons que le tour reparte active et
là bas c'est qu'est-ce que fois je sais
qu'il simonet d'exemple je suis pas sûr
parce que x 5 et 9 ans dames c'est deux
fois le début défense gaz donc ok on va
rien faire j'ai six mais la dame l'a
déjà propose les changes des dames bien
sûr on peut pas prendre cette option qui
var qui va damer et du coup si on perd
mais deux jeux donc ça c'était la bonne
option de jeu pour les noie met donc
faute je projette g5 ben block la
position d'un 24 sous g4 bon pourquoi
pas dams et 2 est d'alger le
donc on va pas aider à prendre
évidemment pas leur deuxième dame mais
de deux lits des deux dames g2 c'est un
peu peut-être venir h 3 et 2 le fleuret
dames faire pression sur aussi par là il
ya eu d'amis si bon il a joué damage 3
qui est pas si mal mais je dois dire que
le plus simple c'est sûrement prendre de
fer forgé cette comme ça la tour ne peut
plus défendre la case et le pion film
n'est pas en défense mais dommage 3 pam
aux mêmes dates des trois roches quatre
dames prend d'amour apprend dame fossé 8
hélas si vous voulez mettre sur pause
c'est pas mal pour chercher un plan bien
voilà donc chercher si vous trouvez vous
ça faisait quand même bloqué on a ceux
qui ont passé on le voyait dangereux
mais pour l'instant la tour défend donc
quoi faire et avec les blancs et a
trouvé un truc sympa 0 h 4 pour 8.5
c'est très bien joué mais se pose est si
énorme fan on pousse genre la tour bouge
et on engage cette escalade alors le
truc je sais pas si la partie est bien
tu es rentrée enfin c'est pas d'ordi est
bien notée on va dire parce que là il va
se passer une série de coups
incompréhensible dans la base de données
à mon avis on ne sait pas la partie
parce que là je joue à noter tour h7
bon bah évidemment on voit qu'il ya
foule prend un échec comprend la tour et
puis on finit avec les pions
sur quoi fil d'or aurait joué fou g7 on
comprends pas parce que la voilà les
noirs pourra faire voilà du coup on
défend l'option qui est important à
défendre et cette sorte de forteresse
on peut rien faire un gâteau reprend g7
au prochain coup et sur quoi les noirs
auraient joué ça et la fin de la partie
aurait été celle là je vous montre un
test rapide
voilà et puis là on imagine les blancs
tout prendre faire qu'une bouchée des
pions mais franchement si la partie ça
je veux bien croire que ça se soit
arrivé mais peut-être eu abandon là mais
surtout racheta toujours personne qui a
peu joué juste sous pression bref donc
cette partie de philidor pas
intéressante quand même parce que il a
su remonter la pente et lettres le plein
et que j'ai 4 notamment voilà paris s'il
a d'abord je crois j'ai quatre chats ces
petits obstacles continuent et avancé
des pions et ouais tout cela s'était
très bien joué jusqu'à là je trouvais
est dommage qu'il ait pas fait faux f6
puisque vraiment bien voilà en tout cas
la gamme glissent est parti donc comme
je disais vous voyez les parties
handicap ça l'empêchait pas de dominer
ses adversaires mais au moins un peu
plus de piment dans la partie donc voilà
partie intéressante et bah allez je vous
dis au revoir on se retrouve bientôt